scegliere
quante volte nella vita dobbiamo
scegliere scelte importanti scelte
fondamentali a volte impulsive qualche
volta consapevoli
senza andare a toccare le scelte più
importanti a volte capita pure dover
fare delle scelte più pratiche più
concrete ad esempio come quella di
scegliere un autovettura nuova
che criteri possiamo utilizzare c'è chi
si affida ai consumi
chi invece sceglie in base alla
sicurezza chi invece ancora in base
all'estetica al colore poi a volte
troviamo pure chi ci dà delle dritte
nelle nostre scelte
ad esempio a me quando dovevo fare un
sopralluogo per scegliere un
appartamento un mio amico geometra mi
disse mi raccomando
portati dietro questi tre oggetti uno
specchio un phon e lì pensavo già che
avesse dei problemi di identità
professionale si sentisse più un
parrucchiere che un geometra e una
pallina il fonti servirà per verificare
che tutte le prese della corrente del
nuovo appartamento funzionino quindi che
l'impianto elettrico sia affidabile
lo specchio ti servirà per verificare
tutte quelle crepe del soffitto e dei
muri che altrimenti ed occhio nudo non
saresti in grado di vedere e la pallina
per verificare se i pavimenti sono in
linea
spesso quando acquistiamo una casa poi
dobbiamo scegliere anche un
finanziamento un mutuo per pagarlo anche
qui ci sono dei criteri per fare una
scelta più consapevole possibile ed
informata come scegliamo questo mutuo
proprio come dovremmo scegliere un
autovettura ad esempio questa macchina
come la vogliamo cabrio cambia a seconda
la stagione se è stata apriamo il
tettuccio e se inverno invece lo
chiudiamo perché altrimenti ci piove
dentro ho sempre uguale a se stesso
quindi come scegliamo il tasto del
nostro mutuo lo scegliamo a tasso fisso
vale a dire con una rata uguale alla
rata iniziale della stipula del nostro
contratto di mutuo
variabile con una rata iniziale che
potrà cambiare durante la durata del
mutuo aumentando o diminuendo
attenzione questo è un mutuo a tasso
variabile scegliamolo solo se siamo in
grado di sostenere un aumento fino al 30
per cento della data iniziale
attualmente forse è meglio scegliere un
mutuo a tasso fisso è probabile che la
nostra economia finalmente possa
riprendersi quindi anche i tassi di
mercato tenderanno ad aumentare
dunque anche il tassi di interessi del
mutuo a tasso variabile potrebbero
aumentare con l'aumento dei tassi di
mercato
quindi in questo momento forse è meglio
scegliere un mutuo a tasso fisso ma
quanto può costare un muto quali sono i
costi di un mutuo un po quando scegliamo
un autovettura quanto ci costa il
modello che abbiamo scelto
dipende dagli accessori che decidiamo di
far montare sopra alcuni sono
fondamentali non possiamo prescindere da
questi tipo il volante il freno così
anche per il mutuo ci sono alcuni
elementi vidal quale non possiamo
prescindere costi fissi come sono
appunto gli interessi questi interessi
sono indicati da il tasso annuo globale
ma non basta per capire quanto ci
costerà al muto perché ci sono altri
costi quindi dobbiamo analizzare quello
che è il tasso annuo effettivo globale
ci dichiara non so gli interessi ma
anche delle spese fisse del nostro mutuo
come ad esempio le spese di istruttoria
che sono quelle che sosterrà la banca
per verificare la nostra affidabilità
finanziaria
le spese di perizia che sono le spese
che la banca sosterrà per fare una
perizia quindi dare un valore sul mobile
per il quale chiediamo il prestito in
base al quale può iscrivere l'ipoteca
l'ipoteca a garanzia del pagamento del
nostro mutuo e poi ci sono delle polizze
alcune sono imprescindibili
come perché previste dalla legge un po
come le nostre cinture di sicurezza
nella macchina nuova che andremo a
scegliere e queste sono le polizze
scoppio e incendio poi in alcuni casi la
nostra banca potrà richiederci altri
tipi di polizze come la polizza vita e
la poli sta per partire di lavoro questi
due tipi di polizze a garantiscono il
pagamento delle rate del mutuo il primo
caso la prima polizza appunto qualora ci
fosse un grave incidente o la morte del
mutuatario e nel secondo caso
garantiranno pagamento delle rate del
mutuo in caso di perdita del lavoro
ma quanto dovrà durare questo mutuo
il consiglio pratico e quello prendete
il mutuo che duri il meno possibile
perché più dura il mutuo più saranno le
rate che pagheremo la nostra banca
quindi più saranno gli interessi che
paghiamo alla banca ma non sempre è
possibile scegliere il mutuo più breve
come non sempre è possibile viaggiare in
ferrari e arrivare prima è necessario
verificare che vi sia una sostenibilità
della rata del mutuo ma la stessa banca
non ci affiderà mai un mutuo con una
rata superiore a un terzo dello
stipendio netto del mutuatario
quindi cerchiamo un giusto equilibrio
tra quello che è la sostenibilità della
data cioè il fatto che la possiamo
pagare tranquillamente è quella che è la
durata del mutuo che solitamente appunto
dura tra i 10 ei 30 anni
ma quello è molto dobbiamo scegliere la
parola d'ordine in questo caso è
comparare quei chiediamo pure il mutuo
nella banca presso la quale abbiamo il
conto corrente
vediamo che offerta ci fa ma compariamo
anche in altre banche
anche perché non per avere il muto non è
necessario avere per forza anche il
conto corrente in quella banca perché le
rate di un mutuo possono essere
facilmente addebitabili su qualsiasi
tipo di conto corrente o attraverso
bonifico
quando però ci rechiamo nelle varie
banche per verificare le varie offerte
attenzioni cerchiamo di farci dare
sempre un
informativa precontrattuale in questa
informativa precontrattuale facciamoci a
dare scritta e saranno segnati i costi e
le caratteristiche del mutuo che ci
viene offerto in modo che poi con calma
possiamo comparare le varie offerte che
ci vengono fare per fare una scelta più
consapevole
una volta che abbiamo scelto banca e
tipo di mutuo appunto in base alle anche
ai costi del mutuo stesso che è il tile
in dieci giorni prima una settimana
prima della stipula del rogito davanti
al notaio per l'erogazione del mutuo
appunto facciamoci consegnare della
banca un altro documento che il
prospetto informativo standard europeo
il ps in questo prospetto saranno
indicate tutte quelle condizioni del
mutuo che abbiamo concordato con la
banca quindi sarà un po la fotografia di
quello che è l'accordo tra noi e la
banca sulla erogazione del mutuo che
dover accordi che sarà preso dal
riferimento dal notaio nella nell'atto
di rogito per
l'erogazione del mutuo e dovrà
corrispondere tra quello che abbiamo
concordato con la banca è quello che poi
verrà scritto da notaio quindi
controlliamo lo bene con attenzione che
non ci siano discrepanze tra quello che
abbiamo accordato e quello che poi è
scritto su questo documento
ecco appunto il notaio il notaio è una
figura professionale
fondamentale è necessario non solo a
garantire la correttezza dei contenuti
dei contratti degli atti che verranno
stimolati per l'acquisto di un immobile
con finanziamento ma anche le parti
stesse fatti notaio andrea garanzia sia
del venditore dell'immobile
dell'acquirente dell'immobile ma anche
della banca stessa gli atti che dovrà
stipulare il notaio per l'acquisto e di
un immobile con finanziamento saranno
tre tipi di atti saranno tre atti
pubblici sarà l'atto di compravendita
tra acquirente e venditore
l'atto di erogazioni di mutuo quindi di
finanziamento tra l'acquirente e la
banca e l'iscrizione dell'ipoteca a
favore della banca
se nella procedere nella scelta del
mutuo abbiamo dei dubbi oppure vogliamo
delle informazioni affidiamoci
tranquillamente al notaio che anche
insieme all'associazione dei consumatori
fa informazione e cerca di rendere
sempre più consapevoli i cittadini nella
scelta delle loro scelte economiche e
infine una volta che abbiamo
sottoscritto
che è stato redatto l'atto dal notaio
resta così per sempre non possiamo
cambiarlo niente affatto come possiamo
cambiare un'autovettura
magari per rottamarla perché sono magari
cambiate le nostre condizioni economiche
così possiamo farlo per il mutuo la
prima cosa da fare come faremo per una
macchina
avremo nell'auto sofia officina che ce
l'ha venduta qui nella prima cosa da
fare che diamo alla nostra banca che ci
ha concesso il mutuo se lo può
rinegoziare
variando la durata il tasso il capitale
ma la banca non è obbligata a
rinegoziare il mutuo
possiamo allora avvalerci di un altro
istituto che si chiama surroga
praticamente possiamo scegliere sempre
avvalendoci della comparazione di un
altro mutuo presso un'altra banca che
magari ci offre condizioni migliori
rispetto alle nostre nuove esigenze
economiche la surroga è un atto
totalmente gratuito per il cittadino
anche le spese notarili vengono
supportate dalla nuova banca e obbligo
però della vecchia banca di consegnare
tutta la documentazione contabile alla
nuova banca entro 30 giorni lavorativi
dalla richiesta della nuova banca alla
vecchia banca bene abbiamo fatto questo
breve viaggio insieme a me non resta che
augurarvi buon viaggio per la scelta del
mutuo migliore per voi in tutta
tranquillità soprattutto in tutta
consapevolezza grazie